[Music]
when we get this up and running we gonna
be out of here Stanford Morehouse
filming this is something I'm st. spent
his entire life trying to do the proves
that time travel to the past is possible
if we just give it some time not scary
but you inspire me
you go in place to see Jay since Pop's
is born I gotta make sure that you get
through I don't need you always playing
Big Brother I'm the only big brother you
got NYPD to move
[Music]
Calvin Walker a 19 year old black teen
was allegedly shot and killed by an NYPD
officer Walker was armed with nothing
but a cell phone I'm so sorry about all
of this I could go I can fix it I would
[Music]
if we just go back get them out of there
then he saved I really have so many
times to get this right everything's
gonna need to be perfect today's date
June 28th Sebastian this has to work
what Richie wait it's about controlling
something we obviously have no control
over my brother didn't deserve this just
missing you how many times if you jump
back CJ we're not superheroes
where is the justice we can't do this
anymore
we only have two jumps left
where's the justice for our sons and our
daughters
in for the whole nation you gotta listen
to us you're going to get killed
you